meanwhile the belarusian president
alexander lukashenko is threatening to
ask for nuclear weapons to be sent from
russia and this comes after voters
approved a change to the constitution
ending the country's non-nuclear status
lukashenko says he'll take the step if
the west transfers nuclear weapons to
poland or lithuania the law change means
such weapons can be on belarusian soil
for the first time
since the fall of the soviet union let's
bring in mark finnoe who's the head of
the arms proliferation with the geneva
center for security policy that's a
think tank that focuses on peace and
security he's also a former french
diplomat joining us from geneva welcome
to al jazeera sir so how significant is
this referendum to allow nuclear weapons
to be stationed on belarusian soil for
the first time in a really long time is
this a worrying development
yes it's it's part of a worrying
series of developments of course because
beerus is a very close ally to russia
it's probably the only
country that putin can count on
and
as you recall the
country when the soviet union collapsed
inherited some of the
former soviet uh weapons on its
territories just like ukraine and
kazakhstan
and those weapons were transferred to
russia
in the case of ukraine it was
done
in exchange for security guarantees from
russia that russia would not uh attack
ukraine and this was done in the we
called
this memorandum
that as we can see is has been under
uh severe
violation severe attack now in the case
of uh
veterans
uh it's part of a
you know a system of
threats
or explicit threats
more directed to
nato than to ukraine itself now it's
it's it's a very
of course very
sensitive and very
dangerous game that
russia is playing
by raising this
risk of
deployment and use of nuclear weapons in
uh
in the case of ukraine right i mean and
we are learning a little bit more as the
days go on of belarus's role uh in the
war in ukraine and even earlier this
evening at the u.n general assembly the
eu ambassador to the u.n um
condemned in the strongest form not only
russia but belarus's involvement in the
war i mean what is
how do you explain belarus's involvement
at this point
well initially as you know robert has
tried to
play a mediating role of course
under strong
pressure or direction from moscow
and that led to the so-called minsk
agreement that were supposed to
help solve the
ukraine crisis with the
the risk of separation from the two
eastern provinces now based on this uh
history
now that russia has
completely shifted its policy and led to
this
military occupation and invasion
parares has almost no choice but to take
part in this operation
and it had actually hosted a part of the
russian
troops that have invaded
ukraine from various territory and now
it's uh
still offering
it's it's its role
to host the
first
potential peace talks
but still
also hosting
russian missiles that have been
shot against ukraine from beerus
territory
and
on the issue of this referendum to allow
nuclear weapons to be stationed in
belarus the eu foreign policy chief has
weighed in and he said that this move is
is greatly worrying i mean how do you
expect the eu
to deal with this going forward
well i don't think that again um bearers
itself uh you know by by itself will
be subject of specific measures it's
it's part of uh
uh now reaction to the russian invasion
with the help of uh batteries bearers
and these subject
sanctions just like russia
it's it's already been actually
sanctioned because of uh
the uh
you know the result of the elections
that were considered
as um
uh
fraud or a coup by the the current
president
and so
and therefore
you know
the the focus really will be
on russia but
bearers will constantly
consequences for
for its action
uh in support of russia okay thank you
so much mark finneau for joining us from
geneva